[Music]
what's up everybody hope you guys are
having a good day
today for us i'm going to show tiff the
being a stepdad video that i made
a week ago and your comments on ig you
were saying how you've never seen this
video
and you're like how did this get shot
edited and uploaded without me seeing it
yeah i had no idea you were working on
this video
yeah i didn't tell you because i was so
freaked out by
just the concept of the video and like
it was just so vulnerable i don't know
i get it the vulnerability part i
totally understand
yeah it was like it was like i was
scared to share it on youtube
and then and i think just because i'm so
close to you there's
even more vulnerability with you and
like how
i didn't know how you looked at me being
a stepdad i just know that you love me
and very grateful for what i do around
the house but i don't know just to put
it on like
that examining table really freaked me
out so i kept it really really hush-hush
and
relate on the vulnerability part because
that's exactly how i felt before doing
my mana video where i revealed that my
dad has been missing for two years like
that was
the most like nerve-wracking moment ever
so i totally relate as to
how you felt about it but now that we're
here and i i saw
the title being a step dad and then i
saw your instagram post and then
i was like oh my gosh like should we do
a reaction video because that that's
such a
an important topic and a vulnerable
topic and it's also a topic
that involves me because it's our family
and so i'm like oh man
i wonder how i'll react but i can
already tell like i'm gonna
just cry my eyes out because i know the
inside view of your journey in being a
step dad so i
i already have that insider knowledge of
what how you feel whatever you have
shared with me
so i'm curious to see what it was that
you put out there for everyone else to
see because
just based off of like i was nosy and i
kind of like quickly scrolled through
the comments of that video and everyone
was like oh my god i'm
sobbing like this is so beautiful and
all this stuff and i'm like oh man
i think i should do a reaction video
because i don't know
anything about this video at all so i'm
really really excited and curious to see
what you said how it all came about like
i don't know i'm just like
what happened because everyone's in on
it right like in on knowing
what this video is about and the fact
that we have been so busy this past week
that we haven't had a chance to actually
sit down so it's been an entire week of
me like
i got to see this video so now i'm like
cool before we begin
let's uh let's talk about this photo
what comes to your mind when you see
that photo okay this photo
the immediate thing that i remember is
the moment i took this photo because i
actually took this photo
so we were in casey's car parked outside
of our house
and i remember it was like su super
early on in the relationship like you
guys had just met
maybe within that week or month or i
don't remember but it was like super
early and i remember you were
mega awkward with isaac super like
really really awkward and shy
and then i was also really awkward in
that whole
dynamic there because i didn't want to
place pressures on you
and to like hey step it up and be a
father for my kid like
because of the relationship being so
brand new i was just like let's all
just see where we all feel and like
where we all stand with this dynamic and
now we're like bringing in a third
person which is my son which is a very
important third person
but up until that point it was just like
seeing our chemistry and how we vibe and
so
by the time i remember like taking this
picture i'm like
you know what i feel like it's already
off to a really great start i feel like
you're gonna be in our lives for
hopefully forever and i i remember
feeling like
i gotta capture this this time right now
like this moment this time
like isaac being four years old i think
he was four in this in this photo
and you know us just starting now to
date and so i remember
isaac was so suit like isaac just as a
kid he's so loving so friendly so
affectionate
and so expressive of his feelings and i
remember he would
constantly try to hug you and like run
to you and like talk to you and all this
stuff and you were just like
hey kid yeah like just really like
like distant a little bit but i
understood the distance like you were
just trying to figure it out but that's
immediately what i think about when i
see this photo is just like wow
early times casey was really afraid or
awkward or shy
whatever it was that you were feeling
and then that face
that face was a was a mask i'm gonna be
cool
but really it was like insecurity and
like being freaked out and then isaac
just
pure innocent soul like geez and then i
remember
all a lot of the photos of this time we
were just kind of like
like really like what i can't do your
face what is it like
i was just like like
yeah whatever and i didn't get
emotionally attached here i didn't you
didn't
phase me yeah actually the whole
emotional
attachment stuff like i for a long time
i was kind of like in this
great area of wait we were getting more
and more serious as before we moved in
i'm like how is it that you're feeling
like
because you were a completely closed
book in that early
early times of our relationship it was
just like i barely was able to read you
or get any sort of like thoughts
out of you because you were just a
closed book you're just
completely like i'm cool i'm stoic like
nothing's fazing me
like everything's chill and so it was
really hard to read
yeah during that time i had a good poker
face
yeah so for a few years maybe help me
open up though over the years
i appreciate that you've worked so hard
on that too and this channel too you
guys and just
doing the vlogs too has been a very like
kind of therapeutic thing
like just looking back and i said well
yeah it's helped me to just express and
talk and like i'm not a talkative person
by nature
too so breaking out that introversion
was a pretty
pretty big for me i would describe
myself more extroverted but
when it came to being extroverted in
front of a lens
that was like a huge hurdle for me so i
i also agree like this channel
completely
helped me like branch out from my
shyness
to the camera but when it came to just
being talkative i could not stop talking
i was so talkative i remember just
trying to like pry
things out of you too like in the early
stages i was actually attracted to like
the
mystery and like what's behind all of
that like let me in
kind of excitement that was the mr
mysterious
yeah you were at one point that's cool
i mean i feel like that's how i was able
to really stick around
and in this relationship because i'm
like you know what you feel the layers
there's gold there i know there is and
so i was right
like see here's the cold yeah excuse my
sniffling
are you crying already you're like no
okay ready
why am i so nervous i'm nervous i'm like
i'm like opening up my heart to you but
it's already like
pre-writ like it's said so i can't even
adjust
on the fly it's like it is
[Music]
all right so this video is all about
what it's like to be a step dad
[Music]
i'm ready i'm strapped
asking me for advice on how to be a step
back because a lot of you guys really
i get a lot of deals but speaking of
shaving before we get to the step-dad
stories this video is brought to you by
harry potter
i'm raising a man he's growing up he's
shaving now it's wild
so i met isaac mind you i was 24 and
having lived baby the bachelor like 24
year old baby
but yeah so tiff was really mindful and
and very respectful
in terms of the expectations are um in
our
unification i guess and i really really
appreciate that because i think
you know had i just jumped right in i
don't think i would have lasted very
long so tiff slowly rolled out the
responsibilities for me
so in the beginning when i finally met
isaac more or less i was just did
something right
just because of some unforeseen
circumstances tiff uh
needed to move out of her place and at
that time i had just moved into a new
apartment and i could definitely have
used
pots you know it's crazy it actually
wasn't at the year mark
it was like a nine no it was at the six
month mark
when we moved in together so so okay the
timeline is
we started dating may right may we
started dating
we moved in at the beginning of december
oh yeah
that'd be like seven months six seven
months yeah so
it was actually less time that i gave
for us to like to uh figure things out
before you came into the picture i think
it was maybe about a solid four
or five months before you met isaac yeah
and then like
a couple months after you met him then
that's when we got into this
situation that you're talking about
where it's like an unforeseen
unfortunate situation where i had to
figure out where to move
so it's actually a lot faster you're
right so it was a lot more like
even more intense yeah it was like a
more abrupt change to your life that's
true
yeah okay resume i'm i am like
wired to think to be a father you have
to be financially stable
you have to be you know like you have to
have made a certain couple steps in your
career
to follow the example
i was a little shy to share that
information with my parents just because
i thought that they would
reject tiff they would reject the fact
that she had
a child already and boy was i
wrong they didn't even hesitate to
welcome tiff into their family
and to welcome isaac into her family i
think something that really helped my
parents accept
tiff and isaac into the into their lives
was the fact that tiff did a fantastic
job with isaac and how well tiff has
managed to raise him
as a single mother uh was a testament to
this
and my parents saw a lot of value
and gave tiff a lot of respect for that
so to my surprise
they welcomed them with open arms and
we've
traveled all over the world ever since
and we've had a lot of good times
[Music]
you that you're allowed to be a child
yeah like there's
just there's this x factor you have to
just grow up so isaac if you ever watch
this video i thank you
for helping me grow up as well
i'm helping you grow up you help me
helped me grow up too
we all grew up together isaac's dad is
in the picture
we all get along and i think that's the
best part about this
unification this family dynamic that's
my favorite literally i would say we
make a pretty good team and we
yeah we make an awesome team find out
what it means to be
a parent in our specific dynamic and
ultimately we know what's the most
important thing here
it's to serve isaac's childhood it's to
serve him growing yeah we always put him
first
day she invited isaac into my life
that was the day we got married
i love my family if any of you guys are
you know become your stepdads or our
stepdad shout out to you guys shout outs
to all the step dads out in the world
feel free to leave a comment let me know
if you have any advice for me
i'd love to hear it and uh until next
time peace oh my god i love
it really he's so sweet baby you make me
cry
oh man i love how you expressed all that
it was just it was really beautiful
thanks
yeah it was really really beautiful yeah
like i remember all those years of
struggle because man it's been hard like
it's been really hard i think like
i look back on all of our struggles and
how far we've come and how much we've
actually grown like everyone in this
family including isaac's dad like we've
all
grown up together like we've all
actually
understood our roles as parents and i
think because of the fact that we've
been able to
have a nice healthy relationship like
we've all been able to
be the best version of ourselves for
isaac
and i don't know i just i'm so happy
because we've been through it
like we really have we've been through
it but it's all worth it
you know because now it's super worth it
it's so beautiful like how isaac's dad
will come over
and spend four hours with us just
chilling just hanging out talking about
like
life and religion and everything like
everything in between
so i think that's that's the really
beautiful part to me
but not just that but also seeing your
growth as a step dad
because there it really was a lot of
trials and tribulations
lots it's just trial and error yeah like
it's
i don't know like being a parent to me
is like there's no
one way to parent and you also have to
like
adjust on the fly like you know like you
know things come up and you just never
know exactly what to do but then you
just have to give it your best and if it
doesn't work
you have to learn to let that go and
then try again
in a better healthier way i'm really
grateful that for you and for foreign to
to be just as malleable and as like
be like water you know you just adjust
on the fly we all just kind of figure it
out as we go and life your throws your
curveball and you just have to move out
of the way and figure out another way
yeah and i think that's what makes you
so special
like you're you're really [ __ ]
special i think you could
like early casey like casey from that
photo if he
was more stubborn or whatever it was
that
that he was when he was at that time
like you know
young and immature and like more selfish
and all that stuff like the fact that
you were able to shed that and grow
and become a man and really like fall
into
your position of the most difficult
position ever
that can ever be thrown at anyone
because i see it from from my
perspective and from the outside but
only
like when i the moments where i try to
put myself into your shoes i'm like oh
my gosh like how do you handle it like
it's it's so
hard because no matter what like how
like in a perfect world we all want to
think like oh you have the exact same
privileges and and like expectations or
whatever it is
as like me and isaac's dad but the fact
of the matter is like
no matter how much we want to make that
be true it just
isn't and just plain and simple isn't
and we try our hardest to
to make that true and make you feel as
equal as possible
like make me not feel like an outsider
but yeah part of the
like real family yeah because that's how
we all see you and how we all
hope to at least for me i'm speaking for
myself at this point then
and that's how how i hope to make you
feel right i don't ever want to make you
feel like an outsider and it's just been
so hard and our our growth and our
struggle
and these positions to like figure out
what
gels and let go of what doesn't and i
think that just really shows that
your character like how strong of a
person you are and how
how loving you are and how how mature
you've become
i'm really proud of you i love you i
love you baby
this is a beautiful video i loved it now
i want to see isaac's reaction oh yeah
like what would he what would he say how
would he feel
i mean you could only guess right yeah i
know how much he loves you
and how much he respects you and how
much he values
you so i would love to see his reaction
too i would love to see an isaac
compilation video from
like when we first started vlogging
until now that's another or even before
we started vlogging
there's a lot of films yeah the bts
videos that's when he was like really
little you could see him there
but yeah that's the isaac i met and the
four-year-old isaac that's in the
behind the scenes of jk film skits yeah
that was the early days i was a
completely different person too yeah i
think
i think we both had our own kind of
baggage coming into our relationship
and then we had that baggage and we had
that baggage to deal with i mean
that's that's every relationship right
we all have our baggage that we bring in
but i think it doesn't have to be as
obvious as bringing a kid into the
relationship to be
baggage like everyone i wasn't even
thinking about everyone has their thing
no but a lot of people see that as oh
yeah you know what i mean i'm just
talking about like past trauma
past experiences you know and there's
things that we come that
are like more like demons you know that
come with us
i think for us to be resilient and grow
from it
and like be here now holding hands like
this
that's so sick i know right it's hard
though it's hard uh
looking at yourself and go you're wrong
that's i think the hardest pill to
swallow yeah for both of us yeah come to
terms with that and then
trying to be better i think our our hard
work has
paid off up until this point yeah it's
only gonna keep paying off
it's gonna keep working there's more
hard work ahead of us that we'll uh
we'll keep it coming i love you
you know what's the part that really hit
me the most was when you were talking
about
like your parents accepting us really
i'm gonna cry again i didn't realize
like how
how much i appreciate that yeah i really
truly appreciate that
like so much because yeah it could have
gone a completely different way maybe
the universe was like you know what you
got some crazy mountains ahead of you
this is this is gonna be like it's not
even gonna be an obstacle at all
true no i think my parents were
definitely
a grace i'm happy that they were very
accepting
they've always been like that too
they've been very accepting of all the
life decisions i've ever made
stereotypical asian parent you know the
fact that they let me you know
dabble in the arts and make a living in
the arts tells you a lot about
you know how they what their world view
is and their acceptance
and uh and then bring you into the
picture and they just loving you yeah
you know i keep getting stuck on the
same words me too
and like so like kind of choked up right
now me too i wish there was a way i
could
open a window and be like here you guys
this is what i do
here you go but to like formulate
words and like all these emotions and
like it's
a difficult task you know what's weird
too when i was making this video
i wasn't particularly emotional about it
no
just like oh just like just vomit
whatever you think and feel
that i didn't get emotional about my own
words until you're reacting to it you
reacting to me makes me emotional about
it really yeah
it's weird sorry
you know if i could give myself advice
to early tiff
i'm glad that you saw the good that she
did
beforehand like you know preparing being
like really sensitive to
not overwhelm you with isaac and stuff
but i feel like another thing i
wish i would have known and be more
sensitive to is also
understanding your entire situation
because i never actually
took time to think about how drastically
your life had changed by the time we
came in i never really considered like
oh you know your career you're off to
that direction you want to go
towards your career because during that
time i'm like yeah go for it like
i'm supportive of your career like go
ahead and do it but i didn't take into
consideration on how you did make
sacrifices for us
i don't think i i ever realized that
like the fact that you stopped taking
music video projects
and you were more considerate of like
getting home
at a certain time because before us
coming into the picture you just come
home whenever you wanted
the life of a vampire yeah pretty much
and then like i just
i didn't fully understand or take into
consideration your sacrifices
i don't think i did and i think that's
why we bumped heads a lot when we were
younger because
i was inconsiderate to your experience
and i i just felt like you were being
inconsiderate to
being a part of the family yeah you know
instead of me actually realizing like
that like
this is a process an adjustment process
it was a lot of like bumping heads that
we both did with
one another and it wasn't until i got
into your industry i left the hospital
because that's another thing that wasn't
mentioned was that
you started taking on more
responsibilities little by little and it
was
kind of due to necessity because i i
no longer was living in the same city i
no longer was able to take isaac to the
same babysitter so then you kind of took
that role
whenever i did have to go to to work
sometimes and yeah me and isaac we'd
come
and we'd bring food to the hospital and
visit you every like night
yeah you guys would bring me lunch so i
thought that was really sweet
yeah it wasn't until i got into your
industry once i left
the hospital that i was able to be more
understanding of what you were going
through
it was also more difficult to understand
because of the fact that you were such a
close book
it was kind of like me trying to figure
things out we did the best we could with
what we had
both of us yeah i think at that time it
was i was definitely
in the mindset of like well i don't want
to tell you how i feel
because i don't want you to think that i
was
uh emotionally weak or whatever you know
and i just kept it to myself and i was
just like i'll bottle it
really not the best thing to do because
when you bottle things up they explode
and we got a lot of explosions
oh yeah not so fun times but there was a
lot of
good that came out of that bad because
it was a lot of growth that happened
necessarily it was all meant to be the
way it happened
i think for a long time i was impatient
i guess with impatient with the process
but now i realize like oh that's
that that was all needed yeah we all we
just had to go through all that
because that was the growing pains
thank you guys so much for watching i'm
sorry if i made you cry
but i hope you enjoyed this reaction
video
i wouldn't say expect to see isaac's
reaction video because
we don't want to put that pressure on
him but maybe one day in the future who
knows
it might come out of him to want to do a
reaction video to this video because
this video
was really sweet and from the heart and
i really enjoyed it thank you for
showing me
thank you thank you for having me
[Music]
hmm